GREG: TO THE HAUSER WENT TO DC.
IT IS TRUE.
MARK STUCK WENT TO THE CAPITAL
WHERE HE MET CREATURES OLD
ENOUGH TO RIDE WOOLLY MAMMOTH ON
THE FROZEN TUNDRA OF SIBERIA.
THIS WAS NOT A HEARING BUT A
HARD OF HEARING.
[LAUGHTER]
WATCHING HIM EXPLAIN HOW THE
INTERNET WORKS TO PEOPLE MISTAKE
IPADS FOR CUTTING BOARDS.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT HOW THEY PRONOUNCED
CHOCOLATE.
>> I LOVE A CERTAIN KIND OF
>> CHOCOLATE.
GREG: I AM SCARED OF HIM.
THE STRANGE MEETING BETWEEN TWO
DIFFERENT WORLDS REMINDS ME OF A
MOVIE.
>> HE CAME FROM SOMEWHERE FAR
AWAY.
OUR PLANET NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE HIM.
HE'S SPOKE A LANGUAGE THAT
BEFUDDLED OUR GREATEST LEADERS.
>> I WOULD DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
ISPS SO THERE MIGHT BE AREAS
WHERE THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
REGULATION IN ONE AND LESS THAN
THE OTHER.
>> INTO CONFUSE THEM AND FORCING
THEM TO ASK FOR RIDICULOUS
QUESTIONS.
>> WILL PROTECT US FROM FACEBOOK
TO TRACK.
>> IS PART OF THE SAME AS
[INAUDIBLE] CONTRACT CAN YOU
>> THE ANSWER THEM IN A LANGUAGE
ONLY HE AND HIS FELLOW ALIENS
UNDERSTOOD.
>> I WILL HAVE MY TEAM FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU.
>> MY TEAM.
>> WITNESSED THE INCREDIBLE
STORY OF A BEING FROM ANOTHER
GALAXY.
HE WAS TORTURED BY HUMANS
STUPIDITY.
MARK ZUCKERBERG AND CARL
WEATHERS.
>> YOU, SON OF A [BLEEP]
>> THE MARK ZUCKERBERG.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: ALL RIGHT.
I FELT BAD FOR THE GUY BECAUSE
NO ONE GOT HIM BUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT AGE BUT ABOUT KNOWLEDGE
WHICH THIS CROWD LACKED.
THAT HEARING IS NOT AN ARGUMENT
AGAINST REGULATION AND FOR TERM
LIMITS AND SMALL GOVERNMENT.
IT'S A GRAMMAR IS 10% THE GENIUS
THAT WE THINK HE IS HE BETTER
HAVE LEFT THAT MEETING OF FULL
ON LIBERTARIAN.
HE WORE A SUIT, FINALLY.
I AM PROUD OF HIM AND I THINK
IT'S HIS FIRST.
>> IS YOUR NEPHEW GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL?
ARE YOU HAVING YOUR FIRST
COMMUNION OR MAYBE YOU ARE GOING
TO THE FUNERAL?
THE FIRST SUPER GUYS WHO NEVER
WORN A SUPER FOUR.
IT'S DESIGNED TO MAKE YOU LOOK
LIKE A BIG BOY ON YOUR BIG DAY.
THAT ALL-IMPORTANT FIRST BUSY
DATE.
>> DO YOU WANT MY JACKET, IT'S
COLD OUT?
>> NO, THANK YOU.
>> GUYS WEARING THAT GO TO JAIL.
>> IT LOOKS GREAT AT WIDELY
COVERED SENATE TESTIMONY.
YOUR MOM WILL HATE YOU THE WAY
YOU LOOK, WE GUARANTEE.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: JAMIE, DID YOU FEEL BAD
FOR ZUCKERBERG IN QUESTION FOR
TEN HOURS?
>> I LOVED EVERY MINUTE OF THIS.
HE SPENT TEN HOURS LISTENING TO
OPINIONS HE DID NOT WANT TO HEAR
BEEN ASKED QUESTIONS HE DIDN'T
WANT TO HEAR POST AND THAT IS
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO GO ON
FACEBOOK.
[LAUGHTER]
IT HAPPENS EVERY TIME I GO ON SO
GLAD HE GOT TO EXPERIENCE IT.
GREG: SHOULD THERE BE CONTENT
REGULATIONS?
>> I THINK THERE SHOULD BE.
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO AND IF
I COULD PICK ONE EVERY TIME I GO
ON FACEBOOK "AFTER WORDS" I FEEL
BAD ABOUT MYSELF.
FOR SOME REASON EVERYONE IS
DOING ALL THESE THINGS AND I
THANK YOU SHOULD HAVE TO DO SOME
NEGATIVE THINGS ON FACEBOOK.
WHENEVER PEOPLE POST AND SAY I
DID THIS AND YOU NEVER SEE
SOMEONE POST THAT I JUST GAINED
20 POUNDS OR I ATE A PIE EVERY
DAY FOR THE LAST 30 DAYS AND I'M
DEPRESSED AND THERE'S A PICTURE
OF THEM HOLDING UP OF SMALL PAIR
OF PANTIES TO FIT INTO.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: I WILL SAY THOUGH, KAT,
YOU DO THAT.
YOU GO ON SOCIAL NETWORKS AND
YOU'RE NOT ALWAYS HAPPY TO BE
SEVEN I LIKE TO KEEP IT HONEST.
GREG: YOU DO.
HOW FAST DO YOU THINK THAT SUIT
WILL END UP IN A PILE WESTMARK.
KAT: I DO NOT THINK HE DID WELL.
I'VE SEEN PIECES OF TOAST WITH
MORE CHARISMA AND THEY DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE BUTTER ON THEM.
I GOT THE BY THAT HE FELT LIKE
HE WAS A TEENAGER BEING FORCED
TO VOLUNTEER IN A NURSING HOME.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT WAS KIND OF THE VIBE.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I THOUGHT.
I LOVED HOW THEY HAD SUCH A
LITTLE IDEA OF WHAT FACEBOOK
REALLY IS BUT THEY DO KNOW THAT
THEY WANT TO REGULATE IT.
GREG: EXACTLY.
KAT: IF THAT IS IN THE GOVERNOR
IN A NUTSHELL I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS.
GREG: WE CAN EXPLAIN IT BUT I
CAN ORDER CHOCOLATE AND THEN
THERE'S THIS AD FOR THE
CHOCOLATE SO HOW DOES THIS
MACHINE KNOW THAT I LIKE THE
CHOCOLATE?
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: TYRUS?
TYRUS: I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
YOU, GREG.
I COULDN'T HELP BUT NOTICE YOUR
LITTLE COMMERCIAL THERE AND
WHERE DID YOU GET THOSE SUITS?
BECAUSE THOSE LOOK A LOT LIKE MY
JACKETS AFFECT.
GREG: I DIDN'T STEAL THEM FROM
BRIAN.
TYRUS: KNOW.
I'VE GOT A FACEBOOK POST FOR THE
GUY WEARING MY SOUP.
HE'S GOING TO GET HIS ASS KICKED
FOR WEARING MY SUIT.
YOU KNOW,  THE WHOLE THING,
CHRIS WAS MY FAVORITE PART.
HE WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION AND
HE KEPT TRYING TO AND ALL HE
WANTED TO KNOW WHERE HIS PHOTOS
WERE OUT THERE IS WANTED TO KNOW
HE WANTED TO KNOW IF HE HAD SEEN
ANYTHING OF HIS STUFF.
HE WAS LIKE, IS THERE SOMETHING
ABOUT REPUBLICANS OUT THERE?
ANY PHOTOS OF GUYS FROM TEXAS
WHO MIGHT BE REPUBLICAN AND IRAN
FOR PRESIDENT AND LOST?
HE LITERALLY ALL HE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT NONE OF HIS STUFF
IS OUT THERE.
THAT'S IT.
YOU KNOW EVERYONE DATA THAT OUT
THERE.
GREG: AT A CERTAIN POINT
EVERYBODY STOPPED THE OTHER.
PRIVACY IS DEAD.
>> ALONG WITH CHIVALRY AND
CIVILITY AND ALL THE OTHER GOOD
THINGS.
GREG: THE ONLY THING ALIVE IS
SCARY.
DO YOU THINK SOCIAL MEDIA
TRAINING SHOULD BE GIVEN TO
EVERYBODY IN SENATE AND CONGRESS
WAS MARKED.
>> I WATCH THIS AND I THOUGHT I
COULDN'T BELIEVE WE ELECTED
THESE GUYS.
WERE DOING A BASIC TELEVISION
SHOW AND I GOT A LIST OF TOPICS
AND LOOK AT ONE OF THEM AND I
HAD NO IDEA I WOULD READ THE
LINK.
THEY'RE NOT EMBARRASSED AT ALL
TO GO SIT THERE.
WE ELECT THEM AND THIS IS THEIR
JOB AND THIS IS THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO THE RESEARCH AND SUPPOSED
TO INSIGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND THEY
HAVE NO SHAME IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
GREG: I WILL SAY THIS.
ORRIN HATCH IS THE ONLY PERSON
WHO KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON WHEN
HE ASKED HER HE BASICALLY SAID
IT'S FREE AND HOW DO THEY MAKE
MONEY AND ZUCKERBERG SAID
ADVERTISING AND THEY BASICALLY
SAID TO PEOPLE THERE YOU ARE A
BUNCH OF IDIOTS.
>> WHICH THEY DIDN'T EVEN GET.
GREG: AND THEN HE SAID THAT IS
HOW THEY MAKE MONEY BY
WORD ABOUT SOMETHING FROM
WIKIPEDIA SO YOU ARE TELLING ME
FACEBOOK ISN'T ACTUALLY A BOOK
OF HUMAN FACES.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKING OF A BOOK OF HUMAN
FACES --
[APPLAUSE]
THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL A NATURAL
SEGUE.
THIS BOOK IS COMING OUT SOON AND
YOU CAN ORDER AT AMAZON AND IT'S
ALL OF MY MONOLOGUES FROM THE
FIVE, NOT ALL OF THEM BECAUSE